The plan for the lesson is this.
We'll start by defining bipartite
graphs, the concept of matchings and
some other needed ideas.
Then we'll show how the problem
of finding a maximum matching
can be reduced to the problem
of finding a maximum flow.
And this will give us
an E times V algorithm.
Next, we'll show that the Vertex Cover
problem is related to the max
matching problem.
Much in the same way that
the minimum cut problem
was related to the Max-Flow problem.
And finally, we'll give
the Hopcroft-Karp algorithm and
show that it finds a maximum matching in
time order E times the square root of V.
There are many good references on
the topic of maximum matchings and
bipartite graphs.
This lesson will follow
most closely Kleinberg and
Tardos' Algorithm Design for
the first three parts.
And Dexter Kozen's, The Design and
Analysis of Algorithms, for
the Hopcroft-Karp algorithm.
We begin our discussion by defining
the notion of a Bipartite Graph.
An undirected graph is bipartite if
there exists partition into L and
R, think left and right.
Such that every edge has one
vertex in L and one in R.
For example,
this graph here is bipartite.
I can label the green vertices as L,
and the orange ones as R.
And then every edge has one vertex,
that's green and one that's orange.
A few observations are in order.
First, saying that a graph is
bipartite is equivalent to saying
that's 2-colorable, for those of you
who are familiar with colorings.
Next, let's take the same graph and add
this edge here to make it non-bipartite.
Note that I've introduced
an odd-length cycle.
And indeed, saying that a graph is
bipartite is equivalent to saying
that it has no odd-length cycles.
For graphs that aren't connected,
it's possible that there will be some
ambiguity in the partition
of the vertices.
So sometimes the partition is
included in the definition.
And we also often draw the graphs
with all the vertices in
one partition on the left.
And all the vertices in the other
partition on the right.